After his debut in Daredevil Season 2, Jon
Bernthal's Punisher was such a huge hit that
he got his own series and at the end of the
last episode of The Defenders, there's a cool
post-credits teaser for Frank Castle's new
solo show.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I'll be breaking down the
new Punisher teaser for easter eggs and clues
on what we can expect from Jon Bernthal's
upcoming series.
Also, I'm running a Punisher and Defenders
giveaway, so make sure you subscribe and leave
a comment for a chance to win a Punisher or
Defenders Funko Pop.
As Jon Bernthal previously revealed in an
EW interview, The Punisher series will heavily
feature Frank Castle's military background.
And, true to this, the new teaser shows quite
a bit more of Castle's military past with
heavy hints at some serious conflicts he got
into during his time in the forces.
You can see his fist here smash the photo
of himself with his colleagues and there's
another shot later where Castle is being held
back from assaulting this guy.
And, if you look closely, it seems like Castle
has given him a nasty injury to his left eye.
I suspect this could be the character William
Rawlins who is played by Paul Schulze, an
actor best known for roles in Nurse Jackie,
24, and The Sopranos.
In the comics, Rawlins was a crooked CIA agent
who engineered various terrorist attacks and
deliberately abandoned his wife Kathryn O'Brien
in Afghanistan.
Later, O'Brien and Castle captured Rawlins
who lost an eye while being interrogated by
Castle.
And there's another shot in the teaser of
Rawlins with what looks like either a glass
or injured left eye confirming that some aspect
of this comic book story will likely play
out in The Punisher.
Comic-book Rawlins also had a hand in drug
smuggling, so I wonder if The Punisher series
will give us any links between him and Colonel
Schoonover, Castle's former Commanding Officer
who turned out to be a major drug lord in
Daredevil Season 2.
The teaser also gives us a glimpse at what
looks like Castle's wife being shot.
Actress Kelli Barrett has been cast in the
role of Frank's wife, Maria Castle.
Maria looked rather different in the photos
of Frank's family in Daredevil Season 2, so
it seems safe to say that her character's
been recast for The Punisher.
What's even more interesting though is that
if this is Maria being shot in her home, this
could conflict with the story established
in Daredevil.
In the tenth episode of season 2, DA Samantha
Reyes confessed that Frank Castle's family
was killed in Central Park when a sting operation
against various gangs went wrong and Castle's
wife and children were fatally injured in
the crossfire.
So, what does this mean for Maria?
Well, either there's something not completely
true about DA Reyes' story or perhaps the
shot in the teaser is a fake-out, either a
warning or threat to Frank from someone like
Rawlins, or even perhaps a hallucination or
nightmare in Castle's mind.
Either way, according to IMDB, Maria is set
to appear in 7 episodes and her children in
four, so it looks like we'll get to see Castle
spend some time with his family in the new
show, for example this shot of him with his
children, sailing past the Statue of Liberty.
Indeed, speaking with EW, Bernthal said that
'the Frank Castle that was in Daredevil is
not in Punisher', so the fact this teaser
shows us that we'll see more of what made
Castle the Punisher, in other words, his relationship
with his family and their fate, as well as
his military past, ties in well with that.
And during a recent interview with Moviefone,
Bernthal talked about taking pains to make
sure Castle wasn't depicted as too 'heroic'
in the new series.
For Bernthal, it was crucial to get across
just how 'brutal, […] damaged, […and]
tortured' Frank is, and he wanted to make
sure they explored his 'pain and what's behind
the violence and the reason he's committing
[it]'.
Speaking of pain and torture, it's not 100%
clear in this scene exactly who's being tortured.
Could it be Castle, perhaps in retaliation
for what he did to Rawlins?
Though the guy's profile doesn't quite look
like Bernthal's to me.
Or could it be showing that Castle's taken
part in torturing this man?
What do you think?
Jon Bernthal's voiceover in this teaser is
also really interesting as it suggests that
The Punisher series is going to delve much
deeper into Frank Castle's psyche.
In the voiceover, Castle talks about having
made a deal with the devil, which ties in
with Punisher's origin story as told by Garth
Ennis in his four-part comic book miniseries
"Born".
In that story, it was a voice inside Castle's
head which helped him deal with the horrors
of the Vietnam War.
And that voice which talks to Frank in the
miniseries may represent either the devil
or death.
In fact, there's a chilling page in the final
issue where, after Frank returns home, he
sees a picture of his own family framed inside
an outline of the Punisher skull, and an inner
voice reminds him that there's a price to
pay.
This links nicely to the line in the teaser
where Frank says "he's coming, he's coming
to collect".
That line not only foreshadows how Frank lost
his family after returning from the war, but
it also teases the vigilante justice we can
expect to see Punisher dispatching to the
criminal underworld in his new series.
As for the repeated image of Frank sledgehammering
a concrete floor, this seems like it could
just be footage for the teaser trailer, although
it does make me think of the scene in the
first John Wick movie where he uses a sledge
hammer to break out his stash of weapons and
gold to go on the rampage against the criminals
who wronged him.
So, what did you think of the teaser for The
Punisher?
And has it got you hyped for the upcoming
full season on Netflix?
Let me know what you think in the comments
below and also subscribe for your chance to
win a Punisher or Defenders Funko Pop.
Coming shortly is my Defenders easter eggs
video, so make sure you turn on your notifications
to get that as soon as it's ready.
If you enjoyed this, don't forget to hit that
thumbs-up button and leave me suggestions
for future videos as well.
In the meantime, you can also check some other
videos you might like right here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!